Hello friends and welcome to your
program 3abn today Bible Q&A Bible
questions and answers here on your very
own network you know it's a privilege
for me to greet you in this hour my name
is Evalia deny and we have a wonderful
panel for you today I know you're
anticipating this program because it is
your opportunity to express your
concerns doubts and questions so this is
your program make the program and we
anticipate your comments and questions
later on in the program I'm going to
share some contact information where you
can send your questions well it's my
privilege to present to you our panel
this this hour and we have Pastor James
raferty who is with us praise the Lord
through technology we can connect hi
Pastor James hi Delia good to be here
with you and Pastor Johnny and uh derell
looking forward to God's blessings amen
amen it's always a blessing to share
this time around the table we learn so
much and it refreshes our memory now we
have darell Thomas with us darell
welcome thank you it's a pleasure to be
here and to open up God's word to get
answers amen amen thank you for all you
do for for the preaching of the Gospel
darl you and your family praise the Lord
very special and I have my very own
personal Pastor John deny
welcome dear thank you it's a blessing
to be here and we want to thank everyone
for sending their questions it helps us
to also learn more from the Lord yes I
love when time comes around because uh
as he is studying he'll say honey this
and that isn't it wonderful to dive into
the Bible so these um men of God are
going to share what they have been
studying getting ready for your
questions well to get started we're
going to have a word of prayer and then
I'm going to share some contact
information with you all could you
please pray Pastor deny sure let's go to
the Lord in prayer Our loving and
wonderful Heavenly Father we want to
thank you because you love us so much
thank you for sending Jesus to die for
us that we may have salvation through
his sacrifice and his ministry in the
most holy place in heaven we ask you now
to bless us with the Holy Spirit we ask
that you will use us we pray that your
children will be blessed all around the
world we ask Lord that you will bless us
with answers from your throne of grace
we ask you in the holy and blessed name
of Jesus amen amen amen amen amen thank
you Lord well as the program develops I
know that you will be reminded of a
question you intended to send to us so
allow me to share the email with you
folks at home you can send your
questions to Bible QA
3abn.org
we have at
3abn official at 3ab
ncore official and we're looking forward
to your comments and questions we're
going to start off with you Pastor raffy
who is joining us from far away thank
God for digital now uh pastor raffy this
is the first question for you this is an
email that we received from Zach from
Australia the question is what does
Daniel 12 mean by time times and half a
time before all things are completed
also what is meant by the two different
periods of time in verses 11 and 12 the
time is
yours thank you Zach from Australia
let's just look at the verses Daniel 12:
11 and 12 it says there that from the
time that the daily sacrifice shall be
taken away and the Abomination that
maketh desolate set up there shall be
1,290 days blessed is he that Waits and
comes to the 1,300
530 days now Daniel 12: 11- 12 is
referring to time prophecies relating to
the attack of the little horn power
against God's Everlasting Covenant this
attack is identified in Daniel 78 and 11
in chapter 7 little horn power Reigns
for 1260 years persecuting God's people
and thinking to change times and laws in
chapter 8 the little horn power puts
itself in the place of Christ and
assumes the role of mediator for sins
obscuring the mediation in the sanctuary
in heaven It cast down the sanctuary to
the Earth by setting up a counterfeit
mediation through an Earthly priesthood
so the question is asked in Daniel
8:3 how long will this imposter Medi
imposter mediation continue in other
words how long is this counterfeit
system going to obscure the mediation of
Christ in the Heavenly Sanctuary the
answer is given in Daniel 8:14 until
2300 days then shall the Sanctuary be
cleansed or made right now that's
referring to the sanctuary in heaven
being cleansed or made right not an
Earthly Sanctuary the 1290 to 1335 are
directly connected to Daniel 8 in the
attack against God's Heavenly sanctuary
and Christ mediation there the specific
time prophecy began in 508 ad with the
establishment of an earlier decree
setting the pope up as the judge of all
men who could be judged by no man that
is the place of Christ being obscured
this led to the papal priesthood system
that could re that was going to receive
a deadly wound in 1798 which is exactly
1290 prophetic days or literal years
from 508 so there's your first time
prophecy fulfilled the 1335 also begins
in 508 but it takes us to 1843 and the
first disappointment of a millerite
movement who after a second
disappointment in 1844 rediscovered the
Heavenly Sanctuary So Daniel 8:14 was
fulfilled with the sanct in heaven being
rediscovered leading to an understanding
of what the Bible calls an investigative
judgment and the Final Phase phase of
Christ's work as Heavenly mediator so
the 1260 takes us from 538 to 1798
points to the Civil dominance of paper
Rome the 1290 the
13335 takes us from 508 to 1798 in 1843
directing us to a counterfeit priesthood
of the papal system that was cast That
cast sought to cast The Heavenly
Sanctuary to the Earth in purpose and
intent so we praise God today that we
have this truth so clearly understand
stood and I really hope that this helps
answer your question if you'd like
further detail on this you can see
program number 114 of Salvation in
symbols and signs available on our 3abn
website and we also have study guides
for the programs amen thank you so much
Pastor rafy well we're moving on with
darell Thomas who's with us here in the
studio uh darell this
um came from Veronica from Indiana and
it says since God is all knowing why did
he create Lucifer and other fallen
angels and Adam and Eve Etc knowing that
they would make bad choices against
their creator why would God create us
knowing we would
sin thank you for your question Veronica
uh and I'll try to answer this in two
parts uh firstly when God created both
humans and angels He created them with
the ability to make perfect moral
choices but when they were created their
choices were not yet permanent just like
mortar takes time to dry both angels and
humans were created with those free
moral choices but they still had to make
those choices permanent in favor of God
uh we're told in the Book of Ezekiel CH
28:1 15 that Lucifer at the time of his
creation was perfect in his ways from
the day he was created till iniquity was
found in him
so God in his wisdom foresaw that
onethird of the angels and that all of
humanity would sin at some point in
their history yet he allowed this
temporary problem to exist so that he
could place uh put in place an eternal
and permanent solution uh to this
problem in nahem 1:9 it says what do you
conspire against the Lord he will make
an utter end of it Affliction will not
rise up a second time now this word
affliction in nahm 1 ver9 actually means
the Judgment that will come to the
wicked whether they be Angels or humans
and this verse also implies that once
evil is judged it will never rise again
and so sin as terrible as it might seem
or as terrible as it is uh will not it
doesn't have an eternal uh uh
characteristic to it the Lord will bring
the plans of the wicked and the wicked
themselves to a complete and permanent
end thus sin will never arise again in
God's universe so this brings us to the
second and most important piece of the
puzzle and that's the cross of Jesus
Christ because were it not for the cross
none of this would have been possible uh
1 Peter 1: 18 to 20 says for you know
that God paid a ransom to save you from
the empty life you inherited from your
ancestors and the ransom he paid Was Not
Mere gold or silver it was the precious
blood of Christ the sinless spot L Lamb
of God God chose him as your Ransom long
before the world began but he has now
revealed him to you in these last days
and so it's true that the introduction
of sin into the world and into God's
Universe brought uh sorrow pain and
death but because of Christ's sacrifice
we can be assured that all of those
things are as temporary as Sin itself in
Revelation
21:4 the Bible tells us that God will
wipe away every tear from their eyes
there shall be no more death nor sorrow
nor crying there shall be no more pain
for the former things have passed away
so God in his wisdom created angels and
humans with the freedom to choose and
with that freedom came the potential for
sin but before there was sin there was a
savior waiting to satisfy the claims of
God's broken law by giving his own life
so let us remember that Christ's
sacrifice uh is is able to restore us uh
if we submit and surrender to his will
and it also ensures that sin and its
effects will never rise up again in
God's kingdom and because of that free
gift we can know that those who populate
God's kingdom will be those who have
permanently chosen to give and surrender
their will to God and so again sin will
never ever rise up again in God's
kingdom and one more thing when we
consider um whether it was wise for God
to put us through uh well we might think
he's putting us through all of this pain
no that God foresaw all of the pain and
suffering that we would go through and
he sent his son his only son to die for
a world who did not deserve it amen
thank you so much daral well we're
moving on to our next question and thank
you Paula from Oklahoma you sent in the
text and the question is addressed John
deny will you please answer it says was
meis EDC actually
Christ well thank you very much for that
question and many people have that idea
that
melkisedek um because of the details
that are presented to us in the Book of
Genesis and in the book of Hebrews they
think that Jes that melkisedek was Jesus
Christ and and unfortunately that is not
correct uh melkisedek was not a
revelation of Jesus Christ but let's go
ahead and go to Genesis
14:17 it says and the king of Sodom went
out to meet him at the valley of shabath
that is the King's Valley after his
return from the defeat of chedo Lair and
the Kings who were with him uh Verse 18
then melchisedec king of Salem brought
out Bread and Wine he was the priest of
God most high and he blessed him and
said Blessed Be Abram of God most high
possessor of Heaven and Earth and
blessed be God most high who has
delivered your enemies into your hand
and he that is Abram gave him a tithe of
all and so some of these details have
led some people to believe oh this must
be Christ but Jesus Christ did not
become priest until after his death and
Resurrection so this cannot be Christ
let's go to Hebrews chapter 7 and
beginning in verse one for this
melchisedec king of Salem priest of the
most high God who met Abraham returning
from the slaughter of the Kings and
blessed him so this is another Factor uh
melchisedec
becomes a a representation of Jesus
Christ in a sense because melkisedek was
both King and priest and Jesus Christ is
both King and priest so mezc just became
a representation of the ministry of
Christ as our high priest we continue
Hebrews 72 to whom also Abraham gave a
tenth part of all first being translated
king of righteousness that is Jesus
Christ as well and then also king of
Salem meaning king of peace without
father and without mother without
genealogy having neither beginning of
days nor end of life but made like the
Son of God remains a priest continually
because of this particular uh idea that
the Bible does not present a genealogy
of melkisedek it doesn't say when he was
born and it doesn't say when he died but
it doesn't mean that he was not born it
doesn't mean that he did not die it's
just the fact that it is is not
presented to us in the Old Testament and
that's why he becomes a representation
of Jesus Christ now uh let's go ahead in
verse 5 and indeed those who are of the
sons of Levi who receive the priesthood
have a commandment to receive tithes
from the people according to the law and
that is from their Brethren though they
were though they have come from the
loins of Abraham but he whose genealogy
is not derived from them received tithes
from Abraham and blessed him who had the
promises and so this is this is why
melkisedek is like a representation of
Christ he was both King and priest Jesus
Christ is both King and priest now
because he did not come from the
levitical priesthood he was of a
different priesthood and that is why
Jesus Christ does not come from the
levitical priesthood notice Hebrews 7:1
therefore if Perfection were through the
levitical priesthood for under it people
received the law what further need was
there uh that another priest should
arise according to the order of MC and
not be called according to the order of
Aaron for the priesthood being changed
of necessity there's also a change of
the law for he of whom these things are
spoken belongs to another tribe from
which no man has officiated at the altar
so Jesus Christ R from another tribe and
this is why there are a lot of
similarities but mkis today was not
Christ amen he was just a man thank you
thank you well we are thankful for jenal
from Tennessee he sent in a text and
we're going to ask Pastor James raffy to
respond to this question why do we
continue having images of Jesus
displayed in and on our literature are
we in violation of breaking the second
commandment with these portraits can you
please explain the second commandment
Pastor thank you Reginal from Tennessee
the second commandment reads in Exodus
24-6 Thou shalt not make unto thee any
gred image or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above or that is in
the earth beneath or that is in the
water under the Earth Thou shalt not bow
down thyself to them nor serve them for
I the Lord thy God am a jealous God
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children under the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
and showing Mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my Commandments
that again is Exodus 24-6 so it is true
that this commandment has been removed
from most Catholic literature the
Catholic catechism for example of 1995
on page 216 simply has an extension of
the first commandment Thou shalt make
make unto you any Graven image nothing
more so the rest of the Commandment is
actually missing the not bowing down
part Etc also theyve made this
commandment a part of the first instead
of it actually being a second
commandment and a long explanation
follows to ensure the reader that Jesus
has ushered in a new era of image
creation and reverence so bowing down to
images is completely removed from the
Catholic catechism and for a good reason
having been raised a Catholic I used to
bow down before images of Jesus and Mary
and the Saints and pray so the second
commandment forbids this and therefore
the reasoning against this commandment
in Catholic lure goes something like
this that is a thing of the past it was
a temporary need definitely not a
problem today now as far as Pi of Jesus
as a man this is not prohibited by the
second commandment at not at all and
unless of course you plan to worship and
reverence the picture now the connection
between images and reverencing those
images is direct and forceable in the
second commandment so pictures of Jesus
are not made to worship they're made to
illustrate however there's a fine line
here if you find yourself worshiping a
picture of Jesus and treating it with
reverence it may be time to toss the
picture I mean if you and if you have a
difficult time tossing the picture of
Christ that would be a fairly clear
indicator that you are in danger of open
violation of the second commandment God
is calling us to worship him and to
worship Him in spirit and truth and not
to worship Him by means of an image even
if it's just a picture so again the
second commandment forbids worshiping
bowing down and worshiping images Idols
the second commandment has been edited
in the Catholic catechism but we see the
second commandment holds fast in the
word of God it prohibits us from
worshiping and reverencing images even
pictures so if you have a picture of
Jesus a picture of God and you have
reverence toward that it's time to toss
that picture those pictures can be used
to illustrate in illustrations of Christ
but we cannot use pictures of Christ as
forms of worship or reverence I hope
this helps to answer your question thank
you very much pastor raferty and thank
you um to you at home thank you for
sending in your questions um we thank
that re Reginal took the time to send it
in and of course we want to share the
contact information once again so that
you at home can send in your questions
so you can email us you can email us at
bible QA 3abn.org
send us a text at 618 228
3975 618 228
3975 and of course we're in Instagram at
3abn official that's at 3abn uncore
official well we want to take the time
to thank Josh he sent in a text and this
is what it says why would God allow
Satan to enter Eden to test Adam and
Eve's obedience could you please answer
that question sure jell sure thank you
and thanks again Josh for your question
and uh one simple answer to this
question is that although Satan and evil
may enter into our environment neither
Satan nor evil have to enter into us for
example consider Jesus being tempted in
the wilderness Matthew 4:1 says then
Jesus was led up by the spirit Into the
Wilderness to be tempted by the devil
now if this verse said that Jesus was
led into the Garden of Eden to be
tempted uh by the spirit to be tempted
by the devil the outcome would have
still been the same this is because
Christ's victory was not dependent upon
his his environment but instead his
victory was because of his connection to
God through the spirit we're told in
Romans chap
8:14 for as many as are led by the
spirit of God these are the sons of God
and then Luke 4:1 expands on on how the
Spirit Led Jesus Into the Wilderness
saying then Jesus being filled with the
spirit returned from the Jordan and was
led by the spirit Into the Wilderness so
Jesus was the son of God he was filled
with and led by the Holy Spirit but this
did not give him give him an advantage
over Adam nor Eve or over anyone who has
been born again so we can all have
access to this same weapon against
temptation but what is this weapon in
the Book of Matthew three times Jesus
was tempted and three times Jesus
responded to those Temptations in
essence saying I will not obey you for
it is written it is written it is
written but this weapon consists in both
what God has written and what God has
said for Luke's account of Jesus
response to the devil in Luke 4:12
expands and says and Jesus answering
said unto him it is said said Thou shalt
not tempt the Lord thy God so this is
important because Adam and Eve were told
in Genesis 2:16 it says and the Lord God
commanded the man saying of every tree
of the garden you may freely eat and so
on so whether it is something that has
been said by God or something that has
been written by God if we abide by what
God has commanded sin can have no
entrance into our hearts so just as
Jesus relied on God's word to resist
Temptation Adam and Eve had the same
weapon available to them but they
refused to use
it and like Jesus we too can be led by
the spirit and filled with his power
thus enabling us to resist temptation
and to abide by God's word and so
scripture is our Ultimate Weapon our
ultimate defense against The Temptations
of the enemy because it reveals God's
truth it exposes the lies of the enemy
and it strengthens our faith thus Romans
6:12 says therefore do not let sin reign
in your mortal body that you should obey
it in its lusts amen thank you boy
starting to sound like preaching here
preaching amen well there is another
question we'd like to get to and this is
from Jackie from California she's
sending an email and I'm sure there are
children as well asking this question
does the Bible say anything about clone
closing your eyes when praying Pastor
deny what does the Bible say about this
well thank you Jackie for the question
and as we look at the scriptures into
the scriptures there are no scriptures
there is no Bible verse that specifies
that your eyes must be closed when you
are praying there is no thus sayith the
Lord you must close your eyes when you
are praying so but this is something
that has been handed down from one
Christian to another parents of course
ask their children okay we're going to
pray put your hands together was there a
Bible verse that says to put your hands
together no but uh putting your hands
together keeps them from doing other
things of course to the children and
then they say close your eyes and close
your eyes and and the children have a
hard time with that but there is no
scripture that says that but when we
consider the fact that we as humans are
easily distracted it would be wise it
would be appropriate to close close our
eyes when we are praying uh things
passing by things that move uh we will
get distracted and God wants our
undivided attention when we are praying
and so closing our eyes is appropriate
to do so and also let's take a look at a
few verses where some people uh did more
than closed their eyes and Genesis 17:3
and Abraham fell on his face and God
talked with him saying so Abraham in
knowing that he was in the presence of
God just fell on his face Exodus
3:6 uh moreover he said I am the god of
thy father the god of Abraham the god of
Isaac and the god of Jacob and Moses hid
his face for he was afraid to look upon
God uh Revelation 1 uh 17 look at this
verse and when I saw him I fell at his
feet as dead and he laid his right hand
upon me saying unto me fear not I am the
first and the last so the uh
understanding that God is Holy and that
uh we should give him our undivided
attention especially when we are praying
it's appropriate to close our eyes and
we would encourage you to do so now I
understand that as you said I have
trouble listening to prayer when the
person praying's eyes are not closed and
so uh it is it may be difficult to to to
to um concentrate as you see somebody
praying like this because it it's
distracting but we encourage you to
understand that there's no biblical
mandate to close the eyes it would be
best it would be appropriate to close
our eyes as I said before because we are
talking to the almighty God Amen and so
I mean uh sometimes when we're talking
to people you know we say and we're
looking around at other places are you
listening to me uh so sounds familiar
you know this is this is us as hum so we
we we should uh close our eyes it's
appro that's right that's right plus uh
you know obviously pray without ceasing
yes it's the direction in the Bible the
council so if you're watching or driving
of course you got to keep your eyes open
you can keep your pray you can pray in
your heart yes that's right oh wow okay
Pastor James raferty this question came
in all the way from New Zealand and we
want to thank Irwin for sending the
email can you can you explain the
context of John
2023 the Bible says that only God can
give forgive sins the then in John
2023 Jesus seemed to give the authority
to his disciples does this mean that man
can forgive sins like some believe what
do you have to say to
Irwin thank you Irwin from New Zealand
great question John 2023 let's look at
the context here starting with verse 22
and when he had said this he breathed on
them saying receive ye the Holy Ghost
whosoever sins you remit they are
remitted unto them and whosoever sins
you retain they are retained now a key
Point here is that the holy spirit is
given as the determining power of action
they're not going to retain and remit
sins without the holy spirit this then
leads to another key point and that's
that the disciples were acting in
concert with the Holy Spirit In addition
the disciples were acting in concert
with each other he was breathing on all
the disciples so this is not the same as
a lone single person taking action by
himself in a box right and a final key
to understanding here is that often and
this is often overlooked is that the
disciples were empowered to remit or
retain sins of individuals in the body
of Christ now we don't talk about the
the retaining part we only talk about
the remitting part uh but the context of
this is retaining and remitting so a
good example of this I think what this
looks like can be found in the story of
ananas and saf in Acts chapter 5 let's
begin with verse one but a certain man
named ananas and safire his wife sold a
possession and they kept back part of
the price which his wife also was privy
to and they brought a certain part and
laid it at the apostles feet and Peter
said to ananas why has Satan filled
thine heart to lie to the Holy Ghost
emphasis and to keep back part of the
price of the land while it remained was
it not thine own and after it was sold
was it not in thine own p power why have
you conceived this thing in your heart
thou has not lied unto men but unto God
and ananas hearing these words fell down
and gave up The Ghost and great fear
Came Upon all them that heard these
things now some people say oh Peter he
killed ananas no Peter just confronted
him with the truth the the death of
ananas was between him and God the Holy
Spirit was the person the power that was
present in this encounter it wasn't just
Peter of course it was the other
Apostles so I had lied to the Apostle
about the money that that he had gotten
from the land earlier and in their
presence he lied about it yet notice
Peter says that why has Satan filled
your heart to lie to the Holy Ghost now
remember the Holy Ghost was what was
breathed upon the apostles by Jesus to
make decisions or determinations about
people in the church when we continue to
read the story it says it was about a
space of three hours when his wife not
knowing what was done with an ananas
came in and Peter answered her and said
tell me if you sold the land for so much
and she said yes for so much then Peter
said unto her how is that you have
agreed together to tempt the Holy Ghost
right the Holy Spirit and so behold the
feet of them that have buried thy
husband are at the door and they shall
carry thee out that's acts 5 7-9 so
again saf the wife of ananas also lies
to the apostles about selling the
property and again Peter addresses his
wife then Peter says unto her how is
that you have agreed together to tempt
the spirit of God so in this instance we
see the meaning of the text in John 20
22 and 23 it's Spirit-filled judgment
given to the apostles to determine that
both ananas and safire were lying to the
Holy Spirit and so being led by the Holy
Spirit the apostles acting in concert
retained right they didn't remit they
retained the sin of an and saf through
the decree of Peter and we also notice
that this power is vested here in church
leaders it's an administrative
discernment along with a power to act in
unison with the Holy Spirit they didn't
kill Anan Isis safire that was the work
of God and so we can't claim this power
to forgive sins uh from this verse as
the personal forgiveness that we see to
a Confessor for in both cases there was
no confession ananas and safire didn't
confess and the power vested was was to
validate the retaining of sins as much
as the remittance of sins and we see a
similar truth stated in Matthew 18 uh
verses 18-2 don't have time to look at
those but you can see the same basic
truth is in Matthew 18:1 18-20 it's an
authority given to the church body as
long as their decisions are in harmony
with Heaven it's not an individual power
to a pope or a priest but a holy spirit
unction or anointing for those who judge
in United Unison with in harmony with
the Holy Spirit I hope that was helpful
thank you so much Pastor rafy we're
moving on to an email that we received
from Frank and darell would you please
get ready to answer this question it
says what led the millerite movement and
others to believe that the Earth was the
sanctuary to be cleansed by the return
of Jesus well uh thank you Frank for
your question uh it's an interesting
question to answer and if we look at
Daniel 8:14 the Bible says for 2,300
days then the sanctuary shall be
cleansed now it might be surprising to
know that when the millerites looked at
this passage they thought of at least
seven different options as to what the
sanctuary in in Daniel 8:14 could
represent and so some of the these
options included Jesus Heaven itself uh
the temple in Jerusalem and they decided
that Jesus couldn't be and and the and
and Heaven itself could not be what this
represents in in Daniel chapter 18 8
ver14 because there's no need to purify
uh these two according to the millerites
and then the third one the temple in
Jerusalem had already been destroyed and
so when they concluded on what the
sanctuary could be they came to two
options we'll talk about one of those
options today which is the Earth itself
in Isaiah 60: 13 uh we're taught that
the uh they they believe that the Earth
was the sanctuary because it says the
glory of Lebanon shall come to you to
beautify the place of my sanctuary and I
will make the place of my feet glorious
and so in their in their thinking uh the
in order for the earth to be the
sanctuary of God it would need to be
cleansed for Isaiah 24: 5 and 6 says the
Earth is also defiled under its
inhabitants because they have
transgressed the laws changed the
ordinance broken the Everlasting
Covenant therefore the curse has
devoured the Earth and those who dwell
in it are desolate therefore the
inhabitants of the Earth are burned and
few men are left hence the the
millerites established the belief that
the sanctuary was the earth and they
determined that the Earth was to be
cleansed by Fire 2 Peter 3 vers veres 7
and 10 says but the heavens and the
Earth which are now preserved by the
same word are reserved for fire until
the day of judgment and predition of
ungodly man but the day of the Lord will
come as a thief in the night in which
the heavens will pass away with a great
noise and the elements will melt with
fervent Heat both the earth and the
works that are in it will be burned up
and so there's many other there are many
other verses that the millerites
utilized to prove this point but the the
consensus belief was that when Jesus
returned he would establish a
Thousand-Year Kingdom upon the face of
the Earth and in order for that to take
place he would need to First cleanse the
Earth uh before he could set that up but
even though the millerites were
incorrect on what constituted the
sanctuary of Daniel 8:4 14 we can know
that they were correct in proclaiming
the imminent soon return of Jesus Christ
and so their cry to the people of the
Earth was F was what we find in 2 Peter
3:1 it says therefore since all these
things will be dissolved what manner of
persons ought you to be in holy conduct
and
godliness amen amen thank you very much
thank you derell now we are thankful
that our family in Christ in South Sudan
are tuning in and we received an email
from Arin and a question is Pastor Dy
would you please answer this one can you
please explain Exodus
353 you shall Kindle no fire throughout
your dwellings on the Sabbath day which
fire is referred to here Aaron asks
thank you Aaron for that question and
it's a very good question in Exodus
chapter
35:3 we find these words you shall
Kindle no fire throughout your dwellings
on the Sabbath day and now this is the
Book of Exodus keep that in mind this is
the Book of Exodus and so what kind of
fire is it well it's an actual fire
where you gather wood and then you
prepare the whole the whole thing in
order to start a fire uh now the reason
why God gave this injunction and I'm
going to call it a temporal mandate was
because God did not want them to cook on
the Sabbath day uh remember Exodus 16:23
it says this then he said to them this
is what the Lord has said tomorrow is a
Sabbath of rest a holy Sabbath to the
Lord bake what you will bake today and
boil what you will boil and lay up for
yourselves All That Remains to be kept
until morning so they were not to cook
on on Saturday it was a laborious
process having to get all this wood and
to cook and some people tested the Lord
and decided to go on Saturday morning to
get the Mana and of course the Mana was
not there they were get supposed to get
a double portion on Friday cook it bake
it or whatever they wanted to do with it
or boil it and then it would be still
good to eat on Saturday so as we look at
Exodus 353 we have to ask ourselves
questions uh for
example time place and condition when
God gives it time place and condition
how long was this supposed to last they
were in the wilderness they were still
in The Exodus part of their journey and
they being in the wilderness did not
have to suffer the cold cold winter and
it would be uh unlike God to say today
to say to them don't turn on any fires
uh in the winter time and because they
would be cold they would potentially
freeze so once they got to the promised
land where there was Winter and where
there could be snow and cold then of
course this mandate not to Kindle a fire
on the on the Sabbath day would not
apply but of course they had to remember
that they were not supposed to cook on
the Sabbath day and I can tell you uh Dr
Thomas Ramirez from Mexico has done
numerous numerous experiments and you
can do them as well the food that you
cook on Friday before the
sunset will remain
fresh compared to food that you cook on
Saturday it will remain fresh longer
cooking it on Friday God still Honors
that he has done numerous experiments
with these dishes and he has put the
things you cook on the dishes and
compared it cooking it on Friday and
cooking it on Saturday and you will see
that there's more bacteria when you cook
it on Saturday then you cook it on
Friday before the sunset it is a very
interesting thing yes it is wonderful
well we are moving on with these
questions and we're going to go to
pastor rafy Pastor rafy are you ready
yes okay thank you Johnny for that
answer and also we are going to the
email we received from Carol and it says
I heard a pastor once say I couldn't
just ask if I have sinned but I have to
be specific how are common everyday
human nature sins forgiven like ordinary
um feelings grumpiness lack of faith Etc
how are common everyday sins forgiven
pastor rafy
well Carol thank you for that question
let me say I certainly feel that
question is it's a good point there are
you know in the Bible there are um some
that confessions that we need to confess
that are specific but there are also
confessions that have to do with our
sinful nature and uh that those
confessions are more General let me just
talk about this in relationship to
Romans chapter 3 and verse 23 the Bible
says there that all have sinned and come
short of the glory of God now there are
two separate points being made in this
verse one is a past tense singular
experience and the other is a present
tense ongoing reality that we're falling
short of God's glory his character his
character of love it's dealing less with
specifics and more with the general uh
selfishness of our of our nature so when
we think about this we think about these
two realities the first one is really
understood like we confess specific sins
we commit and we do that as quickly as
possible we make restitution when when
it's when it's uh possible uh 1 John 1:9
says if we confess our sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness what a powerful promise
the second fits well with the idea that
we generally fall short of God's
glorious character of love this then
requires a general confession that
harmonizes with the idea that's being
presented of falling short of God's
glory right God's character like please
forgive me for being grumpy impatient or
stubborn right that's it's a general
statement so the pastor's right we need
to be specific but there are also times
when we can be General uh it's not just
simply being specific we have uh
confessions that need to be made about
our general failure of character and not
just our specific actions for example I
might ask God to forgive me for being
grumpy to my wife today and I also need
to apologize to my wife too right I mean
derell John
surely you guys do the same thing you
know we and and and the question might
be well would we get tired of making
such confessions like I'm grumpy every
day and I have to confess every day well
I hope we get tired of it in the sense
that we want to stop acting grumpy
toward our spouse right and stop falling
short of God's glory so when we we we
come to this place where we no longer
need to confess our shortcomings um that
would be so powerful but it's unlikely
since God's people as you yourself
stated in your question are so aware of
their ongoing sinfulness I think about
this in relation to people like Isaiah
and Daniel and John who saw Christ and
even though they weren't encountering
any other person like their wife or
their husband they just saw Christ and
they were overwhelmed Isaiah said when I
saw God I was just aware that I was a
man of unclean lips now he doesn't say
specifically what he said like I was
grumpy or impatient I'm just a man of
unclean lips so basically there will be
times when we need to confess specific
sins but the is going to be other times
when we just need to confess in a
general sense the depravity of our
grumpy Fallen honor nature so don't
despair don't be discouraged about that
just give it to God he promises that
he'll finish the work he's begun in US
amen amen praise the Lord and He is
faithful and just well we continue on um
oh darell we have this question and is
from me from mosambi and that's an email
it says is Islam or their prophet in
Bible prophecy is Islam in Bible
prophecy thank you for your question Miu
um because the rise of Islam actually
marked a pivotal time in world history
uh because at this time uh the papacy's
key Ally was uh for both military and uh
political support was the Eastern Roman
or Byzantine Empire and this Empire was
significantly hurt over many years by
the attacks
of the Islamic adherence a number of
theologians also see the rise of Islam
as a judgment against both the bantine
and um papal Authority in Revelation
8:13 an angel was seeing flying through
Heaven at the end of the fourth trumpet
saying wo wo woe to the inhabitants of
the Earth because of the remaining Blast
Of The Trumpet of the a Three Angels who
are about to sound so we see three woes
and three trumpets but today we'll focus
on on one of those which is the first wo
the fifth trumpet of Revelation chapter
9 U beginning in verse 1 and two we see
a star that fell from heaven and he was
given a key to what is called the
bottomless pit or the abyss and then a
furnace like smoke came out of the pit
and was said to cover the Sun and uh the
air with
Darkness now after this took place uh we
see that uh uh in Proverbs 30: 27 uh
sorry in Revelation 9:3 it says that
there came out of the smoke locusts upon
the Earth and unto them was given power
as the Scorpions of the Earth have power
then in Proverbs 30:27 the Bible says
the locusts have no King yet they all
advance in ranks and so the rise of
Islam was compared to the swarming of
locust because of their skill and their
organization in battle and their rapid
expansion across the Arabian Arabian
Peninsula as well as other distant
territories like the Middle East North
Africa and different parts of Europe and
Asia so as Locust without a a king uh a
large number of the uh Islamic adherence
had no centralized government for many
years and this was until uh 1299 when
the Ottomans began a process of UNIF
reunification under a single powerful
state which would later be called the
Ottoman Empire but looking at Revelation
9:10 we read that they had tals like
scorpions and there were stings in their
tails their power was to hurt men five
months now as we quickly look at um the
Daye principle of Ezekiel 46 we see that
this 5-month period was actually 150
years and during this 150 year period
from the year 1299 to the year 1449 the
Ottoman Empire did much to hurt and
destabilize the Eastern Roman Empire
without completely destroying it yet and
so we see as the uh as Islam rose up the
Army significantly shattered the power
of the Eastern Roman Empire and it
forced the papacy to seek other allies
in Western Europe and we know that uh
one of those key allies was the Franks
out of which preceded the French and
what's interesting is that the French
was um what was utilized in order to
inflict a deadly wound in 1798
wow thank you very much
jell we move on to the next and last uh
question of the hour I can't believe the
hour is done uh we received this email
from noren thank you noren and John deny
could you please explain Romans 7 verse
one thank you thank you norin for that
question let's go ahead and read Romans
71 it says or do you not know brethren
for I speak to those who know the law
that the law has dominion over a man as
long as he lives so here it says that
the law has dominion over man as long as
he lives we need to consider that Romans
chapter 7 verse1 comes after Romans
chapter 1 2 3 4 5 and six and what was
said there is a continuation in Romans
chapter 7 and so that's why it says
there let's take a look at a few verses
in Romans chapter 6 to get a context for
this and it says in Romans 6 one what
shall we say then shall we continue in
sin that Grace May abound certainly not
how shall we who died to sin live any
longer in it or do you not know that as
many of us as were baptized into Christ
Jesus were baptized into his death
therefore we were buried with him
through baptism into death that just as
Christ was raised from the dead by the
glory of the father even so we also
should walk in uness of life that is to
be the Christian's decision to walk in
Unice of life but what is this uh
Dominion that we're talking about here
let's continue reading in Romans 6
beginning in verse 11 likewise likewise
you also reckon yourself to be dead
indeed to sin but alive to God in Christ
Jesus our lord therefore do not let sin
reign in your mortal body that you
should obey it in its lust and do not
present your members as instruments of
unrighteousness to sin but present
yourselves to God as being alive from
the dead and your members as instruments
of righteousness to God for sin shall
not have dominion over you for you are
not under the law but under grace so
this idea of sin having Dominion of
dominion over you uh you're not under
the law but under grace notice verse 23
Romans 6:23 for the wages of sin is
death but the gift of God is eternal
life in Christ Jesus our lord what
follows Romans 71 or do you not know
brethren for I speak to those who know
the law that the law has dominion over a
man as long as he lives sin can have
dominion uh over you as long as you live
why because you have these passions that
are described in Romans chapter 7:5 you
have passions to do these sins this a
tendency to do these things and that's
why we are called to die to sin die to
the old way of life and be resurrected
through Jesus Christ and I hope that
begins to to help you in understanding
this question you have to read Romans 5
6 7 and 8 excellent thank you so much
Pastor deny well it's been a pleasure
we're going to take a break right now
and we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
to just share some words from our heart
so James rafy what would you like to say
to our viewing
audience just wanted to reference back
to Carol's question and uh assure her
and each one that God understands the
how we're overwhelmed by our sinfulness
and don't despair keep your focus on
Jesus allow him to uh Pro fulfill his
promise that he will finish the work
he's begun in US amen thank you Pastor
rafy we move on to darell Sure uh I
encourage each and every one of us to
take up our weapon against The
Temptations of the enemy the word of God
and to hide it in our hearts amen amen
thank you very much and Pastor John
deny thank you very much idalia I just
want to encourage people to understand
you know we we dedicate about three
minutes per question because there are
so many questions that come in we're
trying to get to as many as possible but
we do want to encourage you to study
God's word and ask for the blessing of
the holy spirit because when we put
ourselves in the hands of the Lord ask
for his Blessing and understanding ask
him to help us understand he will open
our eyes and of understanding our eyes
of understanding amen amen and Folks at
home family thank you so much for being
part of this program we are awaiting
your questions and your comments as well
we will see you in the next edition of
uh 3abn Bible questions and answers see
you next time
[Music]